now a price cap on Russian oil has come
into force today as the G7 group of
Western countries attempts to increase
the pressure of Vladimir Putin further
joining me now to discuss the situation
retired Air Vice Marshall Sean Bell
Shawn let's talk about um that point
first of all just how much pressure is
this price Gap going to put on the
Kremlin do you think yeah good afternoon
SJ um let's be clear this is only
applies to Russian oil that's being sold
for less than 60 dollars a barrel only
that can be carried by the G7 allies or
or insured by the G7 analy or its allies
um the plan is to make it very difficult
for Russia to sell its oil at anything
more than sixty dollars a barrel sounds
great the trouble is Russia is the
second largest producer of all in the
world next to Saudi Arabia whilst the
West has definitely reduced its Reliance
on Russian oil the spare capacity has
been lapped up by China and India along
the way president zielinski has
described this as a really weak position
for the G7 to take and actually we've
seen the oil price go up over overnight
as a result explosion at Russian air
bases reports of what do we know about
the circumstances surrounding these yeah
so a couple of um unverified explosions
at two Russian air bases uh well behind
the front line Engels and uh D aglevo up
here they're hundreds of kilometers away
from the Battlefront here follows weeks
and weeks of intense Russian bomber
activity targeting infrastructure across
the whole of the Ukraine including today
key varia and zaparita area we've got
Sky verified footage here of the
explosion at um at the Engels Air Base
what we don't know yet
um is the cause of these explosions very
difficult there's lots of speculation we
must be careful not to get drawn into
that what we do know is the Western
Precision military support for Ukraine
is specifically predicated on them not
using any weapons on Russian soil for
risk of escalation so we're pretty
confident it's not that but it could
have been an accident at the air bases
or an actor sabotage angles Air Base is
incredibly busy you've got a satellite
footage here of showing a lot of the
state of the art Russian bombers are
being based out of there this was taken
Just A Week Ago interesting to note
though the Russian Air Force if you wind
back the clock to the start of this
campaign they were flying over 300
missions a day now that's less than 40.
largely because they're running shorter
Precision weapons so the pilots have to
see the Target now before they can
release a weapon winter weather lots of
clouds can't see that massive reduction
in sorties
um let's turn our attention to what's
happening on the ground in Ukraine um
winter well and truly here and the
conditions for the fighting in Ukraine
getting worse by the day they are and
we've just were reporting on our weather
that the cold snap coming to the UK of
-8 um it's minus 20 in Ukraine and
likely getting worse that's pretty
significant two examples of how that
impacts fighting on the ground one of
which is foliage it's very obvious but
the trees shed their leaves the bushes
and here's some footage providing by the
ukrainians targeting Russian positions
draw your attention to the fact though
that you know there's no leaves so all
of a sudden the cover that's provided by
the trees is not there both sides are
using um drones to Target the enemy's
positions and here's a really good
example this is a Russian soldier in the
middle of a little bit of Woodland you
would never have seen him a month ago
because he'd have been covered by The
Woodlands now incredibly vulnerable and
that's one of the challenges of Winter
the other challenge course is clothing
um minus 20 most of us have never
experienced it apart from when you're on
winter operations uh but it's really
difficult to just to survive the West is
providing a load of equipment to the
ukrainians but the Russian conscripts
almost certainly don't have anything
like that and it's very reminiscent of
the 1942-1943 second world war siege of
Stalingrad when the German soldiers 100
000 of them actually froze to death
because they didn't have the right kid
and Equipment
um the winter yeah temper fighting may
have reduced but it's not stopping and
in many ways the fighting is going to
get even more dangerous in the coming
months okay Sean thank you Sean Bell for
the latest there on Ukraine